dr. Li wen Liang is dead five weeks ago
on the 30th of December he noticed a
virus
similar to SARS a killer Chinese virus
from two decades ago he posted a warning
on a Weibo group for fellow doctors
three days later the third of January he
was reprimanded by officials and forced
to sign an apology
Wuhan shut down its food and wildlife
market the origin of the virus on the
same day but then officials delayed a
citywide lockdown and the virus spread
weeks later the city announced the virus
and the official lockdown came according
to statistics that was too late
the virus is now rapidly spreading
through China although it's stabilized
in other countries and the virus is
killing people dr. Li one of many in
life he sparked a national conversation
about freedom of speech in China and in
death he's become a national hero my
deeply regrets his death and feel very
sad we need to see if his death can
change anything and I hope he did not
die in vain China says it's now
effectively dealing with the spread of
the virus
he means Jung Yeo Joo Jinping emphasized
that since the outbreak of the corona
virus the Chinese government and its
people have been making great efforts in
fighting the epidemic but many people
feel otherwise
for them dr. Lee's story shows that
Chinese officials priorities are about
control and political self-preservation
well for more on this I'm joined by
correspondent Matthias Berliner in
Beijing mattias tell us more about this
doctor who has died lee hwon yang was
enough neurologist in a hospital in
Wuhan and in the end of December
beginning of January he noticed an
unusual amount of patients who had been
something that seemed to be a virus
pneumonia now we know it is the novel
coronavirus
he talked about it in a chat group of
fellow doctors and was reprimanded by
the police and told not to talk about it
anymore he sometimes called now a
whistleblower but he didn't even go
public with this he talked with fellow
fellow colleagues and he was punished
for that three weeks later the
government had to admit that this
pneumonia is far wider spread than
anybody would have thought and that it's
it's attempts to cover it up had allowed
it to spread and then we have this
massive lockdown of many places in China
these massive inconveniences for
everybody and this fear of a new disease
that hits everybody this is what makes
his story so touching to people here
well there is a lot of interest in the
story of the hundreds of people that
have died from this virus now why is
this one particular doctors death
getting so much attention this doctors
death seems to galvanize all emotions
that have been built up with people here
in China I see on social media which at
moments that is something similar to
Facebook everybody literally everybody
posting about his death no matter
whether these are people who work in
government institutions or whether these
are people who are critical of the
government who support the government
who are educated who are less educated
this touches everybody because this
virus of course concerns everybody and
his story is very much something that
people can identify with he seems to
have been a regular guy a father whose
wife is pregnant with that second child
went to work who saw something that he
thought he should warn others about he
did warn others about he was right but
instead he was reprimanded by the
government and his warning was not
listened to and this is why everybody is
in this situation he is something like a
martyr of how the government
has handled this coronavirus the tears
we know that authorities in China do
have a tight grip on information flows
do people there trust that their
government will tell them what they need
to know about this epidemic this death
and the reactions to it show that people
do not trust the government he has said
the truth
the government has lied this is what
stirs up the emotions now we can see
lots of posts about him on social media
the government is not able or not
willing to censor everything but it
carefully sends us everything that turns
this death into outright criticism of
the government you cannot post on
Chinese social media phrases like the
government owes him an apology or
freedom of speech would have prevented
this crisis but he is thank you very
much that was correspondent Matthias
bellanger in Beijing